the other day while I was at this
extremely fine fast-food establishment I
realised how humorous it is to listen to
people ordering their food
oh yeah just doesn't want fix that
person got it right they get a number
one so they get everything that is
listed in that value meal but what I
don't get are those people that order
those numbers but don't actually want
the things that are in it then they have
to ask you five million times if you can
switch it around well no that's not what
a value meal is if you're gonna get a
value meal you get everything it's in
the meal oh yes hi I would like to have
the number one please yes that's the ham
egg and cheese croissant with hashbrowns
and a coffee here's the thing I don't
actually want hashbrowns look I just
can't be egg sandwich with the coffee
okay lady so basically you don't want a
number one do you I just want this guy's
like I don't even want the coffee but
you got matter or how about you and
possibly maybe some fruits all right
that's the number one without pretty
much everything um would you like a
punch in the face with that too
[Music]